a faint smile quickly dropped well you
have to resign prime minister is it a
failure of leadership questions the pm
wants to avoid but the su grey report
has put paid to that
boris johnson led to parliament to
navigate his way through conclusions
difficult to read and even harder to
explain there was a failure of
leadership at his number 10 and events
held there should never have happened
i now come to the statement prime
minister to the commons then with a plea
to the public parliament and crucially
his party firstly i want to say
sorry
and i'm sorry for the things we simply
didn't get right and also sorry for the
way that this matter has been handled
and it's no use
saying that this or that was within the
rules and it's no use saying that people
were working hard
[Applause]
this pandemic was hard
for everyone but mr speaker it isn't
enough
to say sorry
this is a moment when let's look at
ourselves in the mirror
and we must learn
an apology and a promise to improve his
number 10 operation i of course accept
sue gray's general findings in full
and above all her recommendation that we
must learn from these events and act now
i get it and i will fix it
and i want to say it
[Applause]
and i want to say
to the people of this country
i know
what the issue is
yes mr speaker yes
yes it's whether this government can be
trusted to deliver
and i say mr speaker yes we can be
trusted
but if the pm wanted to brush over
gray's findings the labour leader pinned
him down
the prime minister repeatedly assured
the house that the guidance was followed
and the rules were followed
but we now know that 12 cases have
reached the threshold for criminal
investigation
which i remind the house means that
there is evidence of serious and
flagrant breaches of lockdown
there can be no doubt that the prime
minister himself is now subject to
criminal investigation
a shake of the head neither he nor his
cabinet much like what they hear
our national story about covert is one
of the people that stood up when they
were tested
but that will be forever tainted by the
behavior of this conservative prime
minister
by routinely breaking the rules he set
the prime minister took us all for fools
he held people sacrificing contempt he
showed himself unfit for office
shut up
order
the mood angry and ugly in this place
the public know this is a man they can
no longer trust
he has been investigated by the police
he misled the house
you're going to have to withdraw misled
just withdraw those words the s p
westminster leader kicked out of the
commons for claiming the pm lied to
parliament
accusations that don't seem to concern
him much but what should be of great
concern is the anger from his own side
starting with the former prime minister
what the grey report does show
is that number 10 downing street was not
observing the regulations they had
imposed on members of the public
so either my right honourable friend had
not read the rules or didn't understand
what they meant and others around him or
they didn't think the rules applied to
number 10 which was it
and upset from the 2019 intake that won
this pm the last election who until now
have been reliably loyal it seems a lot
of people attended events in may 2020
the one i recall attending was my
grandmother's funeral i drove for three
hours from staffordshire to kent
only 10 people at the funeral many
people who loved her had to watch online
i didn't hug my siblings i didn't hug my
parents i gave a eulogy
and then afterwards i didn't even go to
her house for a cup of tea i drove back
three hours from kent to staffordshire
does the prime minister think i'm a fool
eyebrows raised across his benches and
for this former cabinet minister
confidence now lost
when he kindly invited me to see him 10
days ago
i told him that i thought he should
think very carefully about what was now
in the best interests of our country and
of the conservative party and i have to
tell him he no longer enjoys my support
and the big unknown in that place is how
many more of boris johnson's mps
privately agree with those vocal critics
this party is deeply divided but one
thing they can all agree on is that the
sue grey report today doesn't settle
things it's simply too
incomplete the prime minister has said
tonight he will publish the full
findings once that met investigation is
concluded so wait for sue gray becomes
wait for the met judgement day delayed
and the prime minister's allies
confident he can ride this out but
there's no doubt he is still in danger
even those who served in boris johnson's
cabinet not yet fully sold do you feel
more reassured today or is the jury
still out on him and his conduct look i
think uh the truth is the jury's still
out because we haven't come to the end
of this process equality under the law
means that whoever you are whether
you're the prime minister or whether
you're mrs trellis you should be treated
equally and therefore that acceptance by
those in government that the
consequences should be adhered to has to
be at the heart of this and this former
chief whip still reserving his judgment
i don't think he's out of the woods at
all and by the way even though sue
gray's update today didn't have a lot of
facts in it had some pretty scathing
judgments about the lack of leadership
at number 10. i mean it was it was not
comfortable reading for anyone who cares
about our democracy
it could get worse the police now
investigating a dozen potential breaches
of the lockdown rules the team in their
set the pm battle in to keep his mps on
board but what about the public beth
rigby sky news westminster